FIRST, THE LEFT AND DENIAL.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
DIEHARD DEMOCRATS HAVE DEVELOPED
A SEVERE PERSONALITY DISORDER.
THEY DON'T REASON, THEY RAMPED.
>> ALLOWED TO VIEW THAT WERE
MOANING LAST NIGHT AND BEING
MORALLY SELF-RIGHTEOUS, YOU ARE
THE BAD ACTOR!
SAVE YOUR BREATH.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO DIVERT OUR
EYES.
THIS PRESIDENT LIES MORE THAN
ANY OTHER PRESIDENT IN
UNITED STATES PARENTS
>> Laura: FOR MORE THAN TWO
YEARS MOST HAVE LOST ANY SENSE
OF INDIVIDUALITY AND THEY HAVE
ALSO FOUND THEMSELVES ALMOST
COMPLETELY IN THEIR OPPOSITION
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY LIVE FOR ANY HEADLINE
REGARDLESS OF HOW ILL-FOUNDED
THAT SPELLS TROUBLE FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
IF SUCH NEWS WOULD BE BAD FOR
AMERICA, THEY DON'T CARE AS LONG
AS IT IS REALLY BAD FOR TRUMP OR
MEMBER OF HIS FAMILY OR INNER
CIRCLE.
THEY IDENTIFY AS ANTI-TRUMP OR
NEVER TRUMP ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
ARE SO INVESTED IN THEIR
CONSPIRACY WHACK JOB THEORIES
AND NEGATIVE NARRATIVES THAT A
PARALYSIS HAS SET IN.
THEY CANNOT MOVE TO DEEP THOUGHT
OR INTROSPECTION OR HEAVEN
FORBID, CONTRACTION WHEN IT
TURNS OUT WITH THE MUELLER CASE,
THEY GOT IT ALL WRONG.
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION?
NO PROBLEM.
THEY REVERT TO THEIR OLD TRUMP
IS EVIL NARRATIVE.
THEY MAY BE TWEAK IT A BIT AND
THEN THEY PROCEED TO THE NEXT
ATTACK.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING IS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WORKING WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE IS GAMING THE
SYSTEM TO FRAME THE NARRATIVE.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS LEGITIMATE.
HE IS A LEGITIMATE TYRANT.
>> YOU ARE TAKING A VICTORY LAP
FOR NOT BEING VILLAINS.
>> Laura: THIS FROM THE
POLITICAL STAGE OF OUR AGE.
>> I DON'T NEED THE MUELLER
REPORT.
I HAVE A TV.
VILLAINS AND HEROES ARE
PREDETERMINED, BY THEM.
>> Laura: NO INFORMATION WILL
DISRUPT THAT NARRATIVE.
THIS DYNAMIC IS ALSO A PLAY IN
THE PLAY OF JUSSIE SMOLLETT.
THEY WILL LEARN THAT ALL CHARGES
AGAINST HIM HAVE BEEN DROPPED
FOLLOWING A DEAL WITH
PROSECUTORS AS THE ATTORNEY
OFFICE.
AFTER ALL WE HAVE LEARNED ABOUT
THIS CASE, THE TWO NIGERIANS
PURCHASING THE HAT AND THE ROPE,
THE POLICE SAYING HE SENT
THREATENING LETTERS TO HIMSELF.
THE ACTOR HAD THE GALL TO
MAINTAIN HIS INNOCENCE AND
INVOKE HIS MOM FOR SYMPATHY.
>> I BEEN TRUTHFUL AND
CONSISTENT ON EVERY SINGLE LEVEL
SINCE DAY ONE.
I WOULD HAPPY MY MOTHER'S ON TO
FOUND OF ONE DROP WAS CAPABLE OF
ONE DROP OF WHAT I WAS ACCUSED
OF.
THIS HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT TIME.
>> Laura: HE IS THE BAGHDAD
BOMB OF HOAXES.
HAS BRAND REHAB WAS UNDERWAY.
>> MAKE NO MISTAKES I WILL
ALWAYS CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF MARGINALIZED
PEOPLE EVERYWHERE.
>> Laura: THAT IS SURE IF THAT
INCLUDES OTHER PURVEYORS OF HATE
CRIME FRAUD.
HE IS A SUPERHERO IN THAT REGARD
FOR SURE.
OF COURSE THE MEDIA THEMSELVES
OR DENIAL THEY ARE ALWAYS THERE
TO PROVIDE A MUCH-NEEDED ASSIST.
>> IT WASN'T OVERSTEPPED BY THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT TO COME OUT.
HOW WOULD HE EVER GET A FAIR
TRIAL WHEN YOU HAVE THE
SUPERINTENDENT ON
"GOOD MORNING AMERICA"?
>> THE QUESTION ON HOW THE
CHICAGO POLICE GOT SO DUPED.
>> THE NARRATIVE CHANGE FROM
VICTIM TO VILLAIN AND THEN BACK
TO VICTIM.
WE MAY NEVER KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
THAT NIGHT IN CHICAGO.
>> Laura: THINK OF HOW OFTEN
LIBERALS HAVE DERIDED
CONSERVATIVES, ANTISCIENCE AND
ANTI-FACTS.
TWO LEFT-WING FANATICS IF YOU
ARE ANTI-TRUMP WHICH HE IS,
FACTS DON'T MATTER AT ALL!
FORGET THE FACT THAT SMOLLETT
MADE AN OUTRAGEOUS CHARGE TO
ADVANCE HIS CAREER AND FORGET
THE ATTACK COULD'VE BEEN EXCITED
RACIAL OR POLITICAL VIOLENCE IN
THE CITY AND FORGET THAT HE SET
THE CHICAGO POLICE ON A
WILD-GOOSE CHASE.
THE LEFT IS ALWAYS QUICK TO
FORGIVE THEIR OWN.
THE STUDIO THAT PUTS ON A SHOW,
EMPIRE RELEASED A STATEMENT.
>> HE HAS ALWAYS MAINTAINED HIS
INNOCENCE WE ARE GRATIFIED ON
HIS BEHALF THAT ALL CHARGES
AGAINST HIM HAVE BEEN DISMISSED.
TRANSLATION, WE ARE GRATIFIED
THAT THAT CELEBRITY GOT OFF WITH
COMMUNITY SERVICE FOR HIS CRIME
AND THAT THERE WILL BE NO MORE
REPERCUSSIONS FROM OUR LIBERAL
FRIENDS.
THANK GOODNESS, THERE WERE A FEW
CALLED OUT THE ATTORNEY HANDLING
OF THE CELEBRITY CRIME FOR WHAT
IT WAS, A COMPLETE INJUSTICE.
>> MY PERSONAL OPINION IS THAT
YOU WILL KNOW WHERE I STAND ON
THIS.
DO I THINK JUSTICE WAS SERVED?
NO.
I THINK THIS CITY HAS OWED AN
APOLOGY AND THEY CHOSE TO HIDE
BEHIND SECRECY.
I STAND BEHIND THE DETECTIVE'S
INVESTIGATION AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT IS SMOLLETT WHO
COMMITTED THIS HOAX
>> Laura: EVEN THE CLINTON
LOYALIST WITHOUT RUNNING FOR
REELECTION HAD HAD ENOUGH.
>> MR. SMOLLETT IS STILL SAYING
THAT HE IS INNOCENT, STILL
RUNNING DOWN THE CHICAGO POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
HOW DARE HE.
EVEN AFTER THIS WHITEWASH, NO
SENSE OF OWNERSHIP OF WHAT HE
HAS DONE WHAT HE SAYS THAT HE IS
WRONG IN THIS CASE.
IS THERE NO DECENCY IN THIS MAN?
HE SENDS A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT IF
YOU ARE IN A POSITION OF
INFLUENCE AND POWER THEN YOU'LL
GET TREATED ONE WAY ANOTHER
GET TREATED ONE WAY.ANOTHER
THERE IS NO ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THE SYSTEM.
>> Laura: THE DEEP SENSE OF
OUTRAGE AND DISGUST.
EVEN RAHM EMANUEL IS DISCUSSING
THAT, WE SHOULD ALL FEEL THAT.
EVERY AMERICAN ABOUT THE TRUMP
RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX.
THIS IS THE TALE OF TWO HOAXES.
ONE BY SMOLLETT ON THE CITY OF
CHICAGO AND THE OTHER BY
ANTI-TRUMP POLITICAL PARTISANS
IN THE MEDIA ON THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
THE SMOLLETT HOAX WORLDLY CITY,
BUT THE TRUMP HOAX HAD NATIONAL
AND INTERNATIONAL IMPLICATIONS.
IT COULD'VE AFFECTED POLICY AND
THE MIDTERM AND IT IS ALREADY
DESTROYED SEVERAL LAMPS.
ONE OF THE VICTIMS WILL ACTUALLY
BE JOINING US LATER IN THE
SHELL.
AS WE HAVE BEEN ARGUING FOR
MONTHS, THERE MUST BE
CONSEQUENCES FOR BAD ACTORS IN
AND OUT OF GOVERNMENT.
INNOCENT PEOPLE WHO WERE
UNFAIRLY TARGETED DESERVED
JUSTICE AND SO DID THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHOSE MONEY IS WASTED.
WE NEED ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY ACROSS THE BOARD.
A GOOD START WOULD BE THE PUBLIC
MUELLER AND JUSSIE SMOLLETT
REPORT.
THEN WE WILL SEE WHO THE REAL
VICTIMS ARE.